c'est donc un nouveau rendez-vous réussi
pour les opposants à la retraite à 64
ans à Tours vous étiez 15000 selon la
police 20 000 selon les syndicats c'est
4000 de plus que lors de la première
mobilisation une démonstration de force
à la hauteur du rejet que suscite la
réforme du gouvernement chez une partie
des Français dans le cortège tour en
jaune et à Turquie
record battu ils étaient 11600 il y a
deux semaines ils sont aujourd'hui 15000
à défiler dans les rues de Tours selon
les forces de l'ordre du côté des
syndicats l'estimation est à 20000
personnes un mouvement qui prend de
l'ampleur avec toujours plus de
manifestants contre la réforme des
retraites
la dernière fois je pensais que
c'était peut-être pas nécessaire mais là
je pense que c'est vraiment nécessaire
parce que le gouvernement se moque de
nous prochaine fois s'il comprend pas on
sera encore plus nombreux je suis moins
concerné parce que je suis pratiquement
à la retraite mais je pense à mes
enfants et petits-enfants et les jeunes
leur destin c'est eux qui vont la faire
vaut mieux perdre 2 jours 3 jours 4
jours de grève et puis avoir un système
de retraite convenable les syndicats
tous réunis pour cette deuxième journée
de mobilisation parcours identique et là
encore le cortège s'étend sur deux ponts
à la fois ici tous défilent toujours
pour les mêmes raisons on ne dit pas
qu'il ne faut pas réformer on dit que
cette réforme on est pas beau elle ne
privilégie aucune catégorise
professionnelle les 1200 euros pour les
avoir faut avoir travaillé à temps plein
et avoir une SMIC toute sa vie on est là
aussi pour dénoncer les conséquences sur
les carrières longues sur le droit des
femmes à partir à la retraite également
des femmes qui ont souvent des carrières
fractionnées ce qui fait qu'elles n'ont
pas du tout leur trimestre voire partir
dans des manières convenable tout ça
fait que aujourd'hui on ne peut pas
accepter cette réforme
parmi la foule toutes les générations se
mobilisent pour faire entendre leur voix
et les syndicats étudiants et lycéens
font aussi partie des cortèges c'est
pour s'opposer à cette logique qui
pousse à travailler plutôt plus vite
comme la réforme des bacs pro qui
amènera à avoir 50% de stage
dès la seconde pour les lycéens je pense
que la jeunesse elle a largement son mot
à dire qu'elle peut porter sa voix et
qui a d'ailleurs elle fait dans le
Loir-et-Cher la mobilisation est aussi à
la hausse à Blois la police annonce près
de 10 000 manifestants quand les
syndicats en comptabilise 12000